c'est news il est 8h12 merci d'être avec
nous tout de suite c'est la grande
interview avec Marc fenau Marc fenau le
ministre de l'Agriculture qui a donc
choisi ces news et Europe 1 pour parler
ce matin on va revenir sur toutes les
annonces faites par le gouvernement pour
stopper la crise
[Musique]
agricole bonjour mar ch bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous êtes ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire de la France et diosex n'est
pas anodin vous êtes ministre de
l'agriculture depuis 1 an et 8 mois vous
vivez l'une des plus graves crises
agricoles que la France est connue ce
matin la plupart des barrages sont levés
vous vous rendrez cet après-midi dans
l'héros puis dans le gare pour présenter
des mesures concrètes au viticulteurs
avant de rentrer dans le détail de ces
mesures est-ce que vous considérez que
cette crise est derrière vous der
derrière nous ou est-ce que vous êtes en
surs jusqu'au salon de l'agriculture
dans 3 semaines le moment de la crise le
plus le plus
visible manifestement cont tenu des
consignes qui ont été donné par un
certain nombre de syndicats et plutôt
derrière nous mais les sujets de la
crise les sujets que nous avons à
traiter et qui ont qui ont émergé dans
cette crise ils sont encore devant nous
voyz bien qu'il y a des sujets qu'on a
traité immédiatement des sujets on on y
reviendra sur un certain nombre de
filières sur des simplifications
immédiates mais on sait très bien que
les simplifications il faut en produire
d'autres nous avons aussi des débats
européens nous avons aussi des des
sujets législatifs qui viendront dans le
texte que je porterai sur l'orientation
agricole donc le la partie la plus
éruptive ou la plus visible pour chacune
et chacun d'entre nous peut-être pas
vous avez éteint l'incendie il va
falloir reconstruire non mais moi je
crois que les agriculteurs nous ont pas
donné un kitus pour l'éternité si je
peux dire ils nous ont dit on a entendu
les mesures parce qu'on a compris
effectivement ils nous ont dit donc faut
être lucide voyez j'essaie de de faire
un exercice de lucidité ils nous ont dit
on a compris les premières mesures qui
ont été prises on vous on vous en donne
acte ou gage mais il y a des tas
d'autres choses à traiter il y a des
sujets européens aussi qu'on aura traité
donc l'idée n'est pas de lever le pied
l'idée est plutôt d'accélérer sur les
mesures telles qu'elles ont été
annoncées par le Premier ministre aussi
par le Président de la République les
intentions qu'il a donné sur les
questions européenes les agriculteurs
qui attendent des engagements écrits
quand est-ce que vous allez les ils ont
été ils ont été donnés au syndicat hier
sur ce qui a été en fait ça a repris les
les annonces du Premier ministre moi je
me sens dépositaire de ce que nous avons
dit durant cette crise de ce qui a été
dit durant cette crise et de faire en
sorte que petit à petit l'ensemble des
sujets qui ont été mis sur la table soit
soit résolu alors les aides on va
commencer par les aides entre les
premières annonces vendredi dernier et
celle que Gabriel Atal a fait hier il y
a eu beaucoup de promesses ces promesses
sont un coût 400 millions d'euros au
total on va y revenir vous avez promis
150 millions d'euros pour les éleveurs
comment cette somme va va-t-elle être
répartie 150 million chez chez les
éleveurs bah c'est une somme qui va être
répartie sur en fait des allègements
fiscaux et des allègements sociaux qui
permettent au fond c'est de la
trésorerie he qu'on dégage immédiat
ement quand vous avez un stock un ch
versé quand oui ça c'est comme ça que ça
se passera c'est quand vous avez comme
quand vous avez un stock d'animaux vous
êtes taxé sur le stock et tant que vous
l'avez vous êtes taxé alors que en fait
il vudrait mieux être taxé à la sortie
quand vous le vendez et donc c'est une
incitation à garder le troupeau à lutter
contre la décapitalisation puis c'est un
signe important pour les éleveurs en
particulier beauovvin parce que on sait
que c'est un secteur qui souffre depuis
des années qui a besoin d'être conforté
dans son rôle de souveraineté et aussi
d'être donc çaa en majorité à l'élevage
bovinélevage bovin principalement
principalement euh 400 millions d'euros
au total plus les aides pour le GNR vous
confirmez ces chiffres oui alors les les
aides pour le GNR c'est c'est c'est une
avance de trésorerie en fait comme vous
savez le G vous payez la taxe et puis
après vous êtes remboursé en fin d'année
voir un peu plus tard là en avance de
phase à part le guichet a été ouvert
hier donc on est conforme aux annonces
qui avaient été fait par le Premier
ministre en moins de 8 jours euh le
guichet a été ouvert hier vous pouvez
vous faire rembourser à peu près 50 % de
ce qui était votre votre défic qui était
dû par l'État c'est 200 oui c'est ça
c'est 200 millions à peu près ur qui
vont aller dans les exploitations donc
400 millions plus 200 millions qui est
qui est une trésorerie avancée
absolument Berci et Bruno le ma pour
vous vous doutez bien que si nous avons
fait ces annonces c'était la fin du quoi
qu'il en coûte pour sor le vous voyez
bien que dans un certain nombre de cas
on avait besoin de toute façon de
mesures conjoncturelles voire
structurelles vous prenez le cas de la
viticulture on met 80 millions de
mesures conjoncturelles pour faire face
à la crise et puis 150 millions qui vise
à faire quoi à restructurer notre
vignoble et à le préparer pour l'avenir
c'est pas un mauvais investissement
quand c'est sur du moyen long terme et
c'est ça ce qu'on a essayé de travailler
aussi c'est-à-dire d'avoir des mesures
de court terme et puis d'avoir des
mesures de long terme alors une question
sur la méthode du gouvernement par Pho
sont des mesures d'urgence que vous avez
annoncé depuis vendredi dernier mais
pour que ça ça fonctionne personne n'est
dupe il faut changer le le plan européen
sur le plan européen faut c'est à
Bruxelles que ça se passe le président
dit qu'il faut un égalim européen la
France a les moyens de ses ambitions
quand quand en France il aura fallu des
des dizaines de milliers d'agriculteurs
dans dans la rue pour tenter de faire
respecter la loi égal d'abord d'abord
rappelons que c'est la France et elle
seule qui a monté égal mais c'était sous
l'impulsion du Président de la
République en 2017 et qui est venu
rompre avec ce qui était la loi de
modernisation de l'économie fameuse loi
LME et donc c'est nous qui avons pris
l'initiative en France de la loi égalim
on s'est rendu compte que les premières
années ça avait plutôt bien fonctionné
mais que dans le contexte inflationiste
un certain nombre de gens soit par des
centrales européennes soit par d'autres
voie détourner égalim qu'est-ce que ça
dit aussi ça dit que ce que nous avons
porté nous de la rémunération et ça a
été qui est porté par le Président de la
République dans ces différentes
campagnes ça a plutôt fonctionné il faut
mettre en place des contrôles parce
qu'on voit bien qu'un certain nombre de
gens sont en train de les dévoyer mais
ça fonctionnerait beaucoup mieux au
niveau européen parce que ça permettrait
que les l'ensemble des agriculteurs
européens trouvent leur rémunération
vous voyez bien que la crise vous avez
des images de on a des images de BR VO
sur Europe 1 mais il y a des images de
Bruxelles avec Brell derrière nous ou à
côté de nous vous voyez bien que la
crise elle est française et elle est
européenne elle interroge sur la
question de la rémunération et puis
au-delà des galimes on a besoin de poser
sur la table des sujets européens
mais la France a 7 poids aujourd'hui
pour imposer un égal EUR il me semble
que sur les trois sujets qui étaient
ceux qui étaient portés par la France le
sujet
ukrainien le sujet de la dérogation sur
les jachers et le sujet Mercosur la voix
de la France par l'entremise du
président de la République en
particulier elle a pesé me semble-t-il
et donc si elle a pesé ces derniers
temps elle va peser dans les temps qui
viennent mais dans une logique de
coalition on a besoin de trouver des
alliés c'est j'ai porté la voix de la
France sur la question de la jachè on y
est arrivé pourquoi parce qu'à la fin
nous avions plus d'une vingtaine de pays
qui suivaient notre position c'est pas
tout seul la France mais la France elle
a une voix particulière en Europe elle
s'est fait entendre ces derniers mois
ces dernières années sur ces sujets-là
comme sur d'autres d'ailleurs il il
convient de continuer à le faire un
revenu garanti pour les agriculteurs en
clair la loi Galim garantit aux
agriculteurs le fait qu'il ne ils ne
vendent pas leur production à perte
absolument elle doit garantir le fait
que la matière première agricole soit
prise en compte dans le cadre des coûts
de production et faire en sorte qu'on on
ne rémunère pas en dessous des compes de
production les agriculteurs c'est une
rupture historique hein qui a été
produite avec égalim même s'il faut
l'appliquer et qu' y a des gens qui
dévoient la règle Marc F ministre de
l'Agriculture on va prendre de on va
prendre l'exemple du lait ça veut dire
que pour le lait par exemple on va plus
acheter le lait à moins de de de 45
centimes le le point d'équilibr c'est
diff aujourdhui il l' acheté à 40
centimes le litre connaissez le sujet et
40 centimes ils vivent pas il vivent pas
bon il demande 45 50 différent d'un
territoire à l'autre parce que en les
ouioui mais c'est très concret mais
c'est l'objectif qui doit être atteint
il y a un certain nombre d'ailleurs
d'opérateurs de lait qui son donc ça
sera pas le cas demain mais on va la
négocier
devait se terminer le 31 je crois
comprendre qu'il a un certain nombre
d'endroits où la négociation s'est rompu
c'est une négociation il y a un point
d'équilibre qui doit se trouver pour
certains c'est autour de 450 je suis sur
les 1000 l là oui voilà oui ce qui
revient à 4 450 sur gros volume
reconnaissons que parfois 10 ou 20 € des
1000 l ça fait 01 centimes ou vous voyez
ce que je veux dire c'est pas énorme et
donc chacun doit faire sa part de
l'effort c'est un effort continu la
rémunération du lait s'est plutôt
amélioré ces derniers mois ces dernières
années là on est dans un moment de crise
qui justifie a un effort particulier qui
soit fait par les transformateurs et les
distributeurs il y a un gros sujet
également sur l'origine des produits on
a beaucoup parlé du miel qu'est-ce qui
va changer par exemple pour le pour le
miel c'est c'est scandaleux ce qui se
passe avec le miel c'estàdire
que le miel français coûte forcément
très cher à produire et on apporte un
miel qui est pas du tout de la même
qualité et surtout on dit qu'un miel est
français et alors qu'à l'intérieur il ne
l'est pas d'abord on a un problème
d'étiquetage alors il y a un travail qui
a été fait par les députés européens
tous les députés européens y compris
ceux du groupe renew qui un travail
d'étectage qu'on puisse pas appeler un
miel français quand ça n'est pas un miel
français ou un miel italien d'ailleurs
pour les Italiens qui ont produitent ou
les Espagnols donc on a un premier sujet
c'est un sujet d'é on peut pas faire du
mélange comme ça il me semble que c'est
un élément important et donc au niveau
européen on a besoin sur l'ensemble des
productions de pouvoir donner de la
transparence au consommateurs c'est leur
dire vous achetez un produit sachez ce
que vous achetez et avec ça il font ils
font en conscience aussi leur choix mais
il y a besoin de transparence et d'une
meilleure transparence le président de
la
République j'ai emboîé le pas sur le
sujet puisque nous travillons depuis
plusieurs mois il y a une règlementation
européenne qui est en attente sur
l'étiquetage il faut que cette
réglementation européenne soit mise sur
la table par la Commission européenne
pour qu'on puisse en débattre et qu'on
puisse la voter dans des délais qui
soient des délais raisonnables alors
hier il y a un mot qui s'est glissé dans
dans dans vos discours au Premier
ministre à vous Bruno Le Maire c'est le
mot souveraineté vous étiez passé le mot
évidemment
euhême même pas pour tout vous dire on
pas besoin de passer le mot pour parler
de souveraineté à V dire l'objectif de
souveraineté alimentaire on va voir ce
que ça veut dire politiquement mais déjà
très concrètement ça veut dire quoi
l'objectif de souveraineté alimentaire
qui sera inscrit dans la loi qu'est-ce
qui va changer ça veut dire que nous
avons un objectif de politique publique
et qui doit s'aligner euh et qui doivent
s'aligner je parle des politiques
publiques c'est le fait que nous
retrouvions la souveraineté alimentaire
et la sécurité alimentaire en Europe
souver et en France la souveraineté
alimentaire c'est quoi c'est pas
l'autarciie la souveraineté alimentaire
c'est pas l'autosuffisance la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est que nous
décidions que sur un certain nombre de
filières où nous sommes déficitaires je
pense aux fruits et légumes je pense aux
ins
je pense à d'autres filières nous
fassions en sorte de reconquérir cette
souveraineté que nous avions il y a 25
ou 30 ans c'est une l dégradation
auquelle on a assisté pendant 25 ou 30
ans chacun doit prendre sa part je
prends la mienne et donc on doit
réinverser cette tendance là mais la
souveraineté c'est pas la France n'est
pas une puissance export plus de
produits français proposé sur les
marchés c'est surtout plus de production
française qui permettra d'avoir plus de
produits français on a la même chose
d'ailleurs sur la vol la souveraineté
c'est la capacité à reprendre notre
destin en main en matière de production
agricole c'est de ne pas subir une
érosion et de décider des endroits sur
lequels nous avons décidé d'avoir de la
croissance et puis la souveraineté c'est
une souveraineté générale l'alimentation
c'est devenu une arme de guerre
l'alimentation c'est devenu une arme
géopolitique donc la souveraineté elle
est française européenne pour faire en
sorte que nous ne soyons pas à la mercie
à l'extérieur de nos frontières de
stratégies qui soient des stratégies de
chantage à l'alimentation j'ai besoin
d'une agriculture de la souveraineté
alimentaire là j'ai j'ai besoin d'avoir
une une souveraineté qui permette de se
de de rayonner à travers le monde et de
faire la géopolitique il m'importe de
savoir qui nourrit le continent africain
il m'importe de savoir
qui ne pourra pas pour une partie
d'entre lui se nourrir tout seul et donc
je préfère que ce soit nous que d'autres
puissances qui ont des intentions qui
sont moins comment dirais-je moins
pacifiques que d'autres et donc la
souveraineté c'est soi-même sur les
filières et à l'extérieur de nos
frontières de faire en sorte que on
fasse de la de la l'agriculture et
l'alimentation un objet géopolitique
vous parlez vous parlez à l'instant de
de géopolitique l'Ukraine Emmanuel
Macron a déclaré hier oui pour aider
l'Ukraine dans un contexte de guerre
donc importer en Europe des des produits
alimentaires agricoles Ukrainiens non
pour créer une situation de concurrence
déloyale bon une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
veut dire qu'on va arrêter d'importer
des poulets Ukrainiens ça veut dire
qu'on fixe des quotas et des limites à
l'importation de produits alors c'est
c'est là dans les dans les semaines qui
vienne la Commission va déployer son son
plan euhon a beaucoup parlé du poulet il
a également le sucre poulet sucre
et nous avons un sujet sur les
céréal les mesures de soutien à
l'Ukraine il y a un paquet de mesures
financières qui ont été annoncées hier
de 50000 milliard d'euros si j'ai bonne
mémoire qui va permettre de soutir
l'effort de guerre de l'Ukraine l'effort
de guerre ce que nous ont dit les
agriculteurs depuis des semaines c'est
de dire et les agriculteurs français
comme les agriculteurs polonais ou
allemands ils nous ont dit cet effort de
guerre on peut pas en prendre la charge
seul et donc on a besoin de faire en
sorte queil y ait des limites à la
capacité d'exportation de l'Ukraine vers
nos nos contrraits de l'Union à à 27 et
deuxème élément en particulier sur les
céréales il faut que les céréales elles
sortent d'Ukraine pas pour aller chez
nous mais pour aller ailleurs l'Ukraine
c'est une puissance exportatrice
agricole il faut qu'elle puisse
continuer sa bien le blocus qui qui
était prévu à la base ça devait aller
notamment vers l'Afrique et finalement
ça va en Europe rou reconnaissons que
les les œuvres si je peux dire de
Monsieur Poutine qui ont bloqué la mer
Noire et qui ont bloqué les couloirs de
solidarité tout ça avait été fait pour
déréguler le marché d'abord pour mettre
de la dérégulation du marché d'abord
pour mettre de la désorganisation sur le
marché intérieur et pour empêcher
l'Ukraine d'aller sur les marchés
extérieurs hors Union Européenne donc on
doit continuer à les aller ça partira
mais pas mais pas au moins vers l'Europe
absolument c'est ça on a ça a trop
désorganisé les marchés et moi j'ai eu
plusieurs contacts avec mon homologue
ukrainien je dis écoute nous ne pouvons
pas rentrer dans une logique qui soit
une logique de désorganisation de marché
sinon les mesures que nous prenons pour
l'Ukraine vont se retourner contre
l'Ukraine parce que les gens diront les
agriculteurs entre autres diront il y a
quelque chose qui dysfonctionne Marc fen
ministre de l'Agriculture C news Europe
1 la grande interview Emmanuel Macron a
également parlé du Mercosur he traité de
libre échange entre l'Union européenne
et l'Argentine le Brésil l'Uruguay et le
Paraguay suspendu parce que on n pas les
mêmes règles qu'en Europe en Amérique du
Sud est-ce que vous nous dites ce matin
est-ce que vous nous dites ce matin que
le Mercosur est abandonné ou est-ce que
vous nous dites que si on instaure des
clauses miroir comme
l'interdiction d'intégrer dans l'accord
des produits issus de la déforestation
vous pourriez signer l'accord il est
abandonné ou il est suspendu je
reprenons les mots je reprends les mots
du président de la République cet accord
en l'état n'est pas acceptable donc est-
est-ce que cet accord va être acceptable
à date j'ai l'impression que non mais
nous verrons dans les semaines et dans
les mois qui VI VI et je répète ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure 50 % de nos
céréales elles sortent de nos frontières
50 % de notre lait il sort de nos
frontières je ne parle même pas des vins
et spiritueux et donc l'idée que il
suffirait de dire il y a plus d'échanges
pour résoudre le sujet de l'agriculture
française on a besoin d'échanges loyaux
on a besoin d'échang qui ne mettent pas
en concurrence les agriculteurs avec le
reste du monde et parfois même les
agriculteurs avec le reste de l'Europe
et donc on a besoin c'est la question de
la la simplification de la
surtransposition française c'est ça dont
on a besoin on n pas besoin de dire
simplement et de sauter comme le disait
général de GAC maabri en disant pas
d'échange pas d'échang il y aura besoin
d'échange mais ils doivent être loyaux
et s'ils sont pas loyaux il y a pas
d'accord de libre échange le
rassemblement national publie une
nouvelle affiche de campagne pour les
européennes la France soutient la la
ruralité vous avez beaucoup parlé de de
souveraineté pendant votre prise de
parole hier on le disait à l'instant
c'est pour récupérer des voix du
rassemblement national oui oui non ah
mais je non mais je je répondais à votre
question que je croyais être est-ce que
le rassemblement national essaie de
récupérer des voies oui le rassemblement
national en toute occasion il essaie de
récupérer des voies les voilà ruraux ils
deviendront urbains puis ils deviendront
agricoles j'ai pas trouvé beaucoup de
propositions sur le terrain de ces
gens-là moi je suis un élu d'un
territoire rural j'y vis dans une
commune de 700 habitants donc on va pas
me raconter la littérature et me faire
la messe pardon l'expression sur ce
qui'est la ruralité ce qui est le monde
agricole alors que Monsieur bardellaa
découvre le monde agricole que Madame Le
Pen s'en fasse des gorges chos pour
récupérer des voies moi mon sujet c'est
pas de récupérer des voies mon sujet
c'est de répondre aux questions qui sont
posées par la rure qui sont posé par
l'agriculture mais pas dans une logique
de repli sur soi ou de harose sur toutes
les les politiques publiques nous avons
fait des choses depuis 7 ans il faut
aller plus loin manifestement on a des
sujets de simplification qui se sont
sédimentés depuis des années mais cette
cette propension du rassemblement
national à se saisir de toutes les
craintes de toutes les colères de toutes
les désespérances pour en faire un un
porte-drapeau demander aux Anglais aux
agriculteurs anglais qui plensent du du
brexit demandez ce que ça leur a apporté
cette querelle faite à l'Europe rien ça
leur a apporté du malheur des baisses
des aides et une agriculture qui est
coup plus fragile donc moi je ne
récupère pas la colère j'essaie d'y
répondre c'est une grande différence
entre le rassemblement national et nous
c'était la grande interview de Marc F
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire de la France
Merci monsieur le ministre partez dans
les et dans le G absolument dans les G
pour parler viticulture merci d'être
venu ce matin sur C news Europe